Đi các trách trở từ Thế Lắng Sáng Lòng của Sát Huy, ngược lại khi nghiệp bộ mà rắn xuất.
Đi nước ngạc, từ Thế Huy lại trở sẵn lặng bảo lòng trở sẵn gắn.
Tôi theo một助 trình như vậy.
Bây giờ, loại tin các quá trình trở thành đi sảo, từ Thế Lắng Mà Sáng Thế Lắng Tỷ,
Đấy mình ngồi quả trình nống trận.
Mính sỏ vệ quả trình nống trại.
Nghe tăng quân núc, một cái truang hợp đồng,
thĩnh nghĩ tá phản nước,
toái cực đồng nó nó nó nó nó nó trả ra.
Thế cực đồng nó nó nó nó nó trả ra thôi.
Hìa tăng lấy cái đồng nó trả ra, nó nó, nó nộ vào khuống đồng.
Trời nó ngồi đi thì nó xác hình thành thì có trộl,
Đây là sự chuyện tại từ Nắng.
3, 3, 3,
tôi thể là một mà chuyện xác thể làm từ lịch gọi nó đông đặc.
Đông đặc.
Tôi thể là mà xác thể khi là mà xác khi.
Đặc mà xác khi thì người ta gọi là,
nó có quá thời, quá thời.
quá thời.
Vì dụng phải cái hiện được mà hợi.
Cái em cũng nước, cũng nước, cũng suổi.
Điều có này hơi.
Điều có này, như vậy, tương thè làng.
Chị trởi vì hợi.
Đông đặc.
Nếu mà thương thật khi mà xác khi mà xác làng.
Điều có hợi làng quá trình.
hóa lòng hay gọi là mừng độ,
thể ký mà truyền xanh thể răng,
thì người ta gọi là mừng cây,
cây bây,
xù mỗi,
hay là bây,
xù mỗi mà đưa ra yên đường,
tôi được là bây mặt,
như đồ thật,
nó trên,
xanh thể răng,
nó là bây,
khi xanh răng có thể nừng cây,
bây thì tôi thể nắng mắt bây giờ xanh,
được biệt thể ký,
thì cái này gọi là thằng ngua,
bây giờ,
cái viên,
lòng nắng,
mặc em của người,
gây em của chúng nhà bây sinh,
được gạo nướng rất là to,
xanh đó nó,
nó thể nắng,
sổ răng tự truyền,
xanh thể ký,
nó tàng có trần,
tôi nó hay tị tàn mẹ lì,
nó không có trình trình trình là vật,
có người là quá trình trình thể của các chất,
hôm nay mất có trình này,
trái người nãy bộ với dụng đại cho mẹn,
được không?
Nhưng mà em thấy vật lý là nó rắn liền với cửa sống,
các sự vật trình đường sẽ đàn,
xung quần đại,
chỉ không phải vật lý là những bài đón,
phức tạm là những bài đón,
nóc là khó khó phại.